>> Tucker: THE MID-TERM
ELECTIONS 26 DAYS.
AS WE MOVE CLOSER TO ELECTION
DAY, WE LOOK AT PARTICULAR RACES
AND THE CANDIDATES RUNNING IN
THEM.
TONIGHT WE WANT TO TELL YOU
ABOUT KEER CITIZEN CINEMA
RUNNING TO TAKE JEFF FLAKE'S
SEAT IN ARIZONA.
IMMIGRATION HAS BEEN A LONG
ISSUE FOR THEM.
CINEMA IS TRYING TO PORTRAY
HERSELF AS A MODERATE, SOME ONE
WHO SUPPORTS AMNESTY FOR ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND ROBUST BORDER
SECURITY.
THERE IS GROWING EVIDENCE SHE IS
NOT A MODERATE.
IN 2006SINEMA DECLARED THAT
ILLEGAL ALIENS WHO DIE SNEAKING
INTO THE COUNTRY ARE EQUIVALENT
TO AMERICANS DIEING IN THE IRAQ
WAR.
TO SAY IMMIGRATION IS NOT A WAR
OR EQUAL IN MAGNITUDE TO WARY
BELIEVE DISHONORS THOSE WHO DIED
IN THE COUNTRY AND OTHERS ASKING
MY GRANTS.
THE DEATHS THAT PEOPLE SUFFER IN
THE MEXICO ARIZONA DESERT ARE
THE SAME AS THE DEATHS THAT
PEOPLE SUFFER IN THE IRAQ
DESERT.
THEY ARE NEEDLESS, SENSELESS
DEATHS.
THAT'S NOT A MAINSTREAM POSITION
EVEN NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
REVOLUTION WE'RE GOING THROUGH.
THREE YEARS AFTER SHE SAID THAT,
SIMENEMA DESCRIBED IT THIS WAY,
I OPPOSE ALL IMMIGRATION LAWS F
YOU THINK THAT FOREIGNERS
BREAKING YOUR COUNTRY'S LAWS ARE
EVERY BIT AS GOOD AS THE
CITIZENS DIEING TO DEFEND THEM,
IT'S POSSIBLE YOU MAY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH YOUR OWN PEOPLE,
YOUR OWN COUNTRYMEN, THE
CITIZENS OF YOUR NATION.
SINEMA SEEMS TO HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THEM, HERE SHE IS IN 2011.
>> PEOPLE GO INTO ARIZONA AND
SAY THEY'RE SUPER CRAZY.
IT IS SOMETHING IN THE WATER?
THE WATER IS FINE, IT'S FROM
COLORADO.
[LAUGHING]
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH THE
WATER.
THEY JUST, THEY'RE CALLED
REPUBLICANS.
>> Tucker: CHARLIE HERD IS THE
OPINION EDITOR AT WASHINGTON
TIMES, VERY SMART MAN, JOINS US
TONIGHT.
CHARLIE, THINGS HAVE CHANGED SO
MUCH THAT THIS IS NOT
DISQUALIFYING SAYING THAT THE
DEATHS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THE
DESERT, TRYING TO BREAK OUR
LAWS, ARE MORALLY EQUIVALENT TO
THE SOL JESS FIGHTING IN IRAQ.
THREE YEARS AGO IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN OVER.
DOES THIS HURT HER, DO YOU
THINK?
>> I CERTAINLY HOPE IT DOES.
YOU RAISE A GOOD POINT.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN, YOU KNOW,
EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT THIS, WHAT
THE TEA PARTY HAS DONE TO THE
REPUBLIC CAN PARTY.
I THINK THERE WAS HEALTHY STUFF,
FORCING REPUBLICANS TO GET BACK
TO SOME OF THEIR PRINCIPLES.
BUT MY GOODNESS, WHAT WE'RE
SEEING HAPPEN TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, ONCE LEGITIMATE PARTY
THAT WE RELIED ON TO KEEP THE
REPUBLICANS HONEST, OR THE
SUPPOSEDLY CONSERVATIVE PARTY
HONEST.
AND TO CHALLENGE THEM.
THEY'RE GETTING DRAGGED SO FAR
OUT OF THE LEFT OFF THE CLIFF,
THAT I DON'T KNOW, THAT
CERTAINLY WOULD NOT HURT HER IN
A DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY IN ANY WAY
WHATSOEVER.
I DO THINK THAT IT MIGHT HURT
HER IN A EMELECTION.
I MEAN, A LOT OF WHAT SHE SAID
THERE, IT'S KIND OF HARD NOT TO
CONCLUDE THAT SHE HATES AMERICA
F YOU HATE OR BORDERS AND YOU
HATE OUR LAWS ENFORCING OUR
BORDERS, THEN YOU KIND OF BY
DEFINITION HATE AMERICA.
AND THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
CAMPAIGN SHE'S RUNNING ON.
AND THEN ESPECIALLY, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT, RUNNING AGAINST
SOMEBODY LIKE MARTHA McSALLY, AT
THE LEAST SERVED HER COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: CAREER MILITARY
OFFICER.
>> MADE A JOKE OF THE FACT THAT
SINEMA BRAG ABOUT HAVING 100
PAIR OF SHOES, AND McCALLY BRAGS
ABOUT 100 COMBAT MISSES.
WHETHER YOU AGREE WITH THE
FOREIGN WARS OR NOT, AND I HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH THEM, I THINK
THAT YOU TO COMPARE THE
SACRIFICES THAT OUR MEN AND
WOMEN MADE FOLLOWING THE ORDERS
OF THE MILITARY, TO ILLEGALS
CROSSING THE BORDER, AND
TIE-DYEING TRYING TO BREAK OUR
LAWS AND GET INTO THE COUNTRY,
IS ASTONISHING.